it's sad for me to see artists come out
here and die or get hurt and Rob because
yeah I've oh I've never felt unwelcome
here brother I've never felt that and
maybe it's just because of the way I
move and I don't call it checking in
because I'm not paying people for
protection right I'm coming if some of
the brothers or the essays ask me hey
man we're doing a kids program like uh
for example sick jacking and a hood
Santa and then my homie sleeps the the
artist incredible dude they did this um
they did this workshop for kids where
they brought a bunch of different
neighborhoods together from East Lowes
from other places to do art workshops I
was a pleasure to join that and I don't
charge people for appearances I'm like
yo man let me just come there whatever I
can do to offer and lend my voice to
this is something that we need you know
at some point somebody's got to be the
adult in the room